Let's suppose that you're trying to figure out the best places to open a chain of stores in the United States.
So let's say you have a list of cities in the United States.
And here I went and traced a map from the United States.
I can't draw this well.
I traced a map onto the tablet, and I dotted in, I think, the 50 largest cities in the U.S.
And let's say that you're trying to open a chain of stores across the United States, and you want to know
the accessible population of each city, meaning
how many people could easily get to a store in this city?
So let's define accessible population as all the people that live in cities within 300 kilometers of this city.
So these are people who could go for a long drive and get to your store.
How are we going to find the accessible population of each city?
You could launch a thread for each city and have it look at every other city. You get the idea.
And then it could compute the distance to all those other cities, and if it's
under 300 kilometers, then add the population of that other city to a running total.
So in practice, most of these would be more than 300 kilometers away,
and you'd just discard them.
That would be really inefficient, right? You can imagine that--having every city check every other city.
I've only drawn 50 cities here--if I'd drawn
the 2,000, or 3,000, or 10,000 cities that actually exist in the United States,
this would quickly become way too much work.
So instead we could create a spatial data structure, such as overlaying let say a 300 kilometer grid onto the map
and then creating a list of cities that fall in each grid cell.
So this cell will be empty. This one would have 3 cities. This one would have 1, 2, 3, 4 cities.
I think that one has 3, this one is 1 and so on.
Right, so we could make a list of all the cities that fall into each grid cell.
And now if you want to find all cities within 300 kilometers of a given city,
say Denver here, you only need to look at the grid
cell that that city falls in and the neighboring cells.
So I need to check these 3 here.
There are two cities so close together, you can not even tell that is Denver and Boulder. I need to check these cities.
So I still have several checks to make but this is still vastly fewer checks than I would have
to make if I were checking all of the cities against all of the other cities.
So by creating these grid cells, these bins that contain the
cities and therefore being able to restrict which sections, which bins I need
to look in, I've drastically reduced the amount of work that I need to do
to define this accessible population that I'm trying to figure out.
So this is a great example of binning. Let's have a quiz.
Which of the following operations would probably benefit from the geographic binning stage described above?
Suppose that for all U.S. cities in the list we wanted to compute a
histogram of city distances from a central warehouse in Denver, Colorado.
What if you had a list of roads, each of which was represented as a list of line
segments, and you wanted to compute the population of cities within 20 kilometers of that road.
Would it help to use the geographic binning that we described?
Most U.S. cities are in geographic administrative divisions called counties.
To give you a sense of what a county is if you're not from the U.S.,
I've pulled out the Wikipedia map of U.S. counties and I've zoomed in so you can
see some of the counties in our states.
And as you can see there's thousands of counties. There's about 3,000 counties across the U.S.
So given a list of counties and a list of cities, each of which contains an index to the
containing county, the county that it's inside, what if you needed to compute
the city dwelling population of all counties?
Would this geographic binning operation help?